hi everyone and welcome to this webinar
on reinforcement learning in minecraft
challenge and opportunities in
multiplayer games
my name is diego pereira leona i'm i'm a
lecturer
on computer games and ai at kubernetes
university of london
i'm part of the gaming group as the same
as two of my
core presenters in this webinar look
again and
martin bala who will talk after me
they're also
part of the gaming group there are psd
students in industry of london
and then we have a final speaker with
sam dublin from microsoft research who
will close
this presentation during this webinar
we're going to talk about four main
parts the
in the first one i'm going to introduce
the main concepts and ideas we have
general
game ai research after me reluc again i
will talk about different games that
have been implemented in minecraft and
can be used
for this particular area of research
after raluca martin bala will be talking
about how to train different
reinforcement learning agents
in malmo the the main platform for
multi-platform game multi-agents
games in minecraft and finally
sam dublin will be talking about several
open questions
and research that is happening at the
moment in this
in this domain so starting with the
first block
general game ai research traditionally
in
in game ai something that we have done
quite useful quite
often is to utilize different games and
doing different research on those games
so for instance you could
create an ai agent that is going to play
one particular
game could be a game on a 3d game like
minecraft could be
games two-dimensional games like for
instance sequest or could be other
navigational games in which you have to
maybe control a ship in a in an
environment
and then maybe visit a series of
waypoints normally the ai the way it's
focused is you have a particular agent
and you try to create this ai so it
plays the game
as best as it can while this advances
the field in many cases we are
interested
in similar approaches that could focus
on one
ai agent that is able to play multiple
games this allows the researchers
to focus exclusively on the ai
methods on the actual technology behind
the agents rather than in specifics on
every game
so we can advance ai in order to
to make a ai method that are applicable
to many
different domains and not only one
particular one
examples of these can be found in the
literature one example you might have
heard of
is the work on the atari learning
environment
with using deep convolutional neural
networks and deep qns
that allow you to receive as an input
image of the game and then analyze it
try to extract features automatically
and then map that to the different
outputs
that the agent can take essentially the
actions that the agent can take in the
game and then
by progressively and repeatedly playing
these games he's able to learn
and he's able to play better and better
as time progresses
another example for could be the general
video game ai foreign competition
this is something that we have developed
at queen mary and essentially the idea
is that you can play multiple arcade
games
in in a fashion in which you don't have
to train on them
you have access to the model of the game
and you can plan which are the best
actions
and you can play multi multiple games
like could be space invaders
or soccer band or things more complex
like for instance
portals or other games like for instance
could be also
butterflies or orcella
this was against the competition and
allowed people to train
and prepare agents even not knowing the
games that they're going to be
playing with later on in a more general
case more general example
we have stratega which is a general
strategy games framework that we have
been developing
this for instance try to tries to tackle
more complex situations in which you
have games
that require decision in multiple
dimensions like for instance you might
be defining how to do
research or different technologies or
you might be controlling multiple units
that you need to be managing at the same
time
or you might also try to for instance a
managed economy
or playing against multiple enemies in
this case we are developing this
this framework that allows you to play
multiple different strategy games at
once
and trying to focus research on the
difficult questions of decision making
for these domains
but one clear example of one
one of the main platforms at the moment
multi
games development is the project malmo
which is developed by microsoft
and is using minecraft as a platform for
doing ai research
you can find all the information in
these links as well but in general this
takes the game minecraft with all these
complexities to offer a rich
diversity of games that you can use for
training and learning
with your agents in these environments
so the main design principles of malmo
are that they have a low entry barrier
so you essentially can can create your
own
agents in the in the language that you
prefer could be java.net c
c plus part python or lua it's cross
platform so you can essentially use it
in multiple operating systems like
windows linux or macos
uh in general incorporation api for
agents
so you can create an agent
biasing or basing your your um your
agent in several functions that you can
implement in order to interact with
environment the
actual environments as well can be
created in xml so you can
essentially define how does the world
look like the type of objects the type
of
elements that are incorporated into that
and also you can incorporate
how is the task itself that you want to
you want to develop
like you can define the actions that are
available for the agents you can also
define different rewards that exist
how does the episode end what you have
to do to win sense
so given that you have all these
possibilities all these languages to
define different games
you we are moving in malmo from just
executing
agents in one particular domain to
arrange the wide range of domain that
you can
you can work and this allows that to
focus in
a more general multi-task learning
rather than focusing on the narrow ai
of one simple environment not only that
but also you can use
malmo to have multiple agents in the
same game so for instance if you're
playing
maybe a football game or when you
capture the flag like the examples on
the screen
you could have multiple agents each one
of them controlled by a different
ai algorithm or controller they are
trying to
either compete in the same game or
trying to cooperate to achieve a common
goal
or even you have a human who's playing
with all these ais
and there is an interesting aspect of
collaboration and competition between
the ais and the humans
that can be also explored in this domain
this is the introduction from project
malmo
and now rolex again is going to talk
about the different
agent different games that have been
created
examples of tasks that are interesting
for doing ai
in this particular environment
thank you diego my name is alka and i
will be talking about the multiplayer
games
available in the framework we currently
have three different games
that are all parameterized with
procedural level
generation behind them as well and that
is to allow for many variations
of each of the environments to be
generated to allow for diverse and
challenging training settings
for general players the first game
is mob chase previously known as pic
jays which was used in a previous
microsoft collaborative ai challenge
the point here is for two different
agents to corner a mob
in a fenced off play area they get a
large reward for catching the mob
and a smaller individual reward if they
move to an exit block instead
which could be the better choice if the
partner of the agent is not actually
cooperating
in order to play this game the agents
have
three actions available here they can
move forward backward or turn
they have the goal the main goal of
catching the mob which
awards them the most points and they
have a secondary goal
of reaching an exit which should also
end the game
but award them a fewer number of points
and all of the games that we have here
also have a maximum number of commands
that can be sent by the agents
so this is to encourage them to actually
complete the problems as fast as
possible
with the current parameter options which
can be easily modified
and increased to cover more potentially
interesting spaces
we can get over 6 million variations of
mob chase
not including the various level layouts
resultant from the chosen parameters
we can vary the look of the game the
number of
objects in the level and their position
within
a varied size play area all of which can
be used to also tweak
the difficulty of the game if needed
these are some examples of what the
games generated
might actually look like in practice mob
chase
specifically targets ai skills based on
cooperation
chasing navigation and exploration
the next game that we're looking at is
build battle
in which two different agents compete
here to build
a given structure one agent placing a
block correctly awards in points
which subtracts from the opponent
here the agents can move forward
backward or turn
but they can also jump and they can
place or destroy objects
the main goal of the game is to copy the
given structure
with towards one point but here we can
also see a more granular
reward structure we towards a small
number of points for placing
correctly some blocks or removing
incorrectly placed blocks
and the opposite for placing blocks in
incorrect positions or removing blocks
that have already been placed correctly
and we have an opposite reward scheme
for the opponent
here we can obtain over 10 000
variations of the game
not including different level layouts
and we're varying
things like the size of the structure to
be built
and the overall level size the look of
the game through the types of blocks
used
and the percentage of the structure that
is already built for the players to
generate
interesting challenges of varying
complexity
and to look at this game in action we
can see two different instances here
build battle specifically targets ai
skills based on
navigation puzzle solving and resource
management
and lastly we have treasure hunt in
which one agent
is defenseless and has the mission of
collecting treasure
the brightly clock the brightly colored
blocks
in the pictures and videos shown here
and then make it to
the exit of the dungeon as well the
other agent
is equipped with a sword and must
protect the collector from the enemies
as they navigate the dungeon together
multiple teams
of collector protector players could be
added in the same game
for an interesting competitive angle and
in this game the agents can
again move forward backward or turn but
they have also different about abilities
depending on their particular role in
the challenge
the protector can attack enemies and the
collector
can interact with the items in the level
and collect them
goal overall is for the collector to
reach the exit
and we again see here a more
granular reward structure with points
awarded for
each of the treasure blocks being
collected as well as
agents being penalized if any one
of the ones in the same team die
over 3 billion variations of this game
can be created by varying the look of
the game
combat aspects and the number of enemies
faced
as well as the overall and detailed
configuration of the dungeon
in these examples we're only seeing some
one-room play areas
but larger and more complex dungeons can
easily be generated
and this is what the game looks like in
action
treasure hunt is one of the more complex
scenarios
that we have available which targets
many ai skills such as navigation
exploration
object transportation and escort aiming
defeating enemies
chasing fleeing and obstacle and harm
avoidance
overall the games that we have available
in the framework
pose a wide variety of challenges
requiring the agents to exhibit
many different skills in order to
successfully solve
all of the problems thank you very much
for listening
and i will pass on to martin we'll be
talking about actually training agents
to play such games
thank you thank you rolker hi
my name is martin bala and after
seeing how the missions are in mamo
we turn our attention to how to get an
agent
to successfully play these games so for
this we use
reinforcement learning in reinforcement
learning
an agent interacts with an environment
initially
the environment gives gives the agent
an initial observation and based on that
observation
the agent picks an action the action
gets
into the environment and the environment
updates its internal state and returns
the next observation with a reward the
agent's objective
is to accumulate the highest discounted
reward
as it can the observations in minecraft
are the are in the form of rgb
pixels and the action space in the
simplest form can be
moving one grid forward turning 90
degrees left or right
and the reward is in the simplest case
minus one or one one is
when the agent successfully completes a
mission
a minus one when it fails the next is to
have a look at how to actually set up
marmo on your own machine
it got a bit simpler than with previous
versions
so the first step is to get java version
and python 3 installed unfortunately
minecraft runs with
an older version of java so it requires
java 8 specifically it wouldn't work
with newer versions
and after you get java and python
installed
the next step is to clone the repository
and if you got this cloned then you can
install momo and using pip
and if you want to run the examples and
the tutorials from the repository
then you can optionally install the
example sub package but if you want to
get it to
run on your own machine refer you to
your
to the project's readme so
we use rliv for our examples
rliv is part of the ray project
you might have come across this as
ray is a popular python package to
speed up computation by parallelization
rle provides high quality
state-of-the-art
easily scalable rl algorithms so you can
run the same algorithm on your laptop
and easily transfer it to a cluster
and you just have to change the
resources
that you have available so you can
specify more cpus
and more gpus and rlev automatically
handles that and it supports both
tensorflow
and pi torch so if you
don't want to learn the other framework
it's not a problem we prepared a few
notebook tutorials to lower the entry
barrier for
mamo we recommend you to go through
in the order listed in the slide
as they build from basic concept to more
advanced ones so the first tutorial
is about how to run a random agent in
malmo
it shows you how to set up the
environment
and then it just samples random actions
at each time step
the next tutorial shows how to
use rlev and run a ppu agent
in a sample mission
then we go through how to restore a
checkpoint
and how to evaluate the checkpoint
and finally we are going to show you an
example of how to run a multi-agent
experiment in mamo and rliv
the first notebook is about how to run a
random agent in mamo
so the first thing we have to do is
create
the environment calling manuem.make and
then
for the initialization we have to pass
the mission file
with a port and that port is going to be
used to communicate between
java and the python process and
we have the launcher which automatically
starts up the java
minecraft instance it just requires
an array of ports in this example we
only use a single port
and a launch script that we explain
in the next slide and then
we can just use the normal reinforcement
learning group
and in this example while the episode is
not over we just sample
a random action at each time step
so it's worth highlighting how the
launcher works
so previously you have to manually start
up the
minecraft instances using a gradle
process for
each environment that you wanted to use
and instead
we created a python script that does it
for you
and the launcher takes in an array of
ports and for each port
it starts a new minecraft instance
and it also takes a launch script the
launch script
is a bash file that defines the launch
options for minecraft
so by default it renders
a window on your desktop but that
doesn't work on
for example had less linux machines if
you want to train it
for longer periods on a server and
you can use xvf to
export the display and
that helps you running it that was one
of the issues that
we had with the earlier versions of mamo
the next example is how to run
a ppu agent in malmo
ppo is one of the state-of-the-art
reinforcement learning algorithms it
stands for
proximal policy optimization
and we are using the tune api
that helps you run an experiment
so it's quite straightforward to run it
in the first line
as the first argument you define the
algorithm
so in this case we use ppo then we
give a config which is a python
dictionary that defines the
algorithm's parameters so it defines the
learning rate and the available
resources so you can define how many
cpus you want to allocate
and how many gpus then we set the
stopping conditions that
it makes the training stop after a
certain number of
environment agent interactions and then
we have some checkpoint
argument it creates a checkpoint at the
end and also throughout training
after every few in the
algorithm iterations it makes a
checkpoint
and finally we set the log
there so everything that rle blocks it
just
saved at a specific place after training
we can visualize the 10 server output
that rlip automatically saves we don't
have to wait
until the end of the training we can
visualize it
during training and we have some a few
example
what kind of data we can visualize so it
shows the
average length the episode text 12
training the maximum and the average
rewards
that it collected during the episode and
rlip collects much more data so for
example you can visualize
even cpu usage or memory usage and
sampling time in milliseconds there are
much more these are just a few examples
and then after we trained an agent
we can visualize what it does the gif on
the right
is recorded using the screen recorder
that we
also provide in the framework it takes
the observations that the agent gets
and saves them as i give or an mp4
file the the mission
was the single agent mob chase in this
example
the agent just has to navigate to the
brick block
that the agent does very nicely on the
gif
so in the next tutorial we have a look
at how to restore
a reinforcement learning agent in marmo
so one use case for this is that you
train an
agent you have the checkpoint but you
want to visualize
what it actually learned so in this case
you can just
change the configuration that you you
may want to just use a single cpu and
for example no gpu
for the visualization you can
switch off exploration so the agent
picks the best action it can
at each time step and then we can use
the same
radio tune function as before
but now on the last argument we use the
restore flag
and we provided the checkpoint file that
we had
before and then
we may want to evaluate an agent
as you've seen the tune api doesn't have
the same flexibility
as we have a normal agent
so we may want to use a different level
or we may want to get more insight of
what the agent
does in the environment so
in this case it's better to load the
agent's trainer so in this case we load
the bpo trainer
we restore the checkpoint file that we
had
and then we can directly access the
policy
in the reinforcement learning group that
we've seen
in the random agent example we can call
a policy.compute action
and give it the current observation and
it doesn't just return the
action but it also provides the
action distribution the value function
and any other algorithm specific
quantities
for example it can provide q values
and then we can use that the best action
that the algorithm has and send it to
the environment
and then before we move on to the last
tutorial
on mutagen reinforcement learning we
have a look at how the mutagen setup
works in marmo
so so far we only had single agent
examples
where each minecraft instance was
attached to a single agent
in the multi-agent setup there are
multiple roles
and for each environment there is an
agent withdrawals 0
that's going to act as the server and
all the
other roles are going to act as clients
and once we establish the mission
all the clients connect to the server
and they have this synchronized
observation
and to do that in code
we have to use an additional helper
function to create a multi-agent
environment where we define the agent
configuration
so that's where we assign the roles to
the agent
then we use these turn based rla voltage
and and
wrapper it's turn based in the sense
that each agent acts at the same time
so they are not asynchronously acting in
their
own time and then
in this in a similar rate the tune the
trend function
now we use the multi-agent argument
where we define how the policies
are defined so
in this example we use a shared policy
which means that
both of the agents are going to have
identical weights
but they act in a decentralized manner
so they don't share information or
observation
within each other to do that we also
need to define the
observation space and the action space
and a policy mapping function but you
can
find more information of this in the
rlip documentation
okay so after you've trained the ppa
agent on the multi agent
setup you should see
something like this on the left side the
agent is withdrawal zero it acts as the
server
and the right size window is the
client and in this mission
the agent should collaborate and catch
the
chicken or they can decide to not
collaborate and just move to the
sand tile which one of the agent does
and
sam in the next section is going to talk
about
ways that you can make reinforcement
learning
agents learn how to collaborate so to
sum up
what is in the queen mary malmo
repository
we added the launcher that wasn't in the
previous repository
and the updated p package so it's
more convenient to call the launcher for
example
and also we have some updated
documentation we also have the
notebooks that i mentioned previously
and we also provide normal python
scripts
so if you don't want to use the
notebooks it's fine you can
use the scripts instead that might be
much easier to use in your own project
and we also provide some additional
helper functions
for example an observation wrapper that
just converts the
minecraft observations to any arbitrary
size
and we also have a video recorder that
you could see the single agent
recording earlier and we also have a
symbolic representation
extractor so so far all the examples
were based on
image input and the
symbolic representation extractor it
gives you a top-down
view of the symbolic representation of
the environment
that could be helpful for your project
finally we provide two ppo checkpoints
one for the single agent mob chase
mission
and one for the two player watches
next sam is going to talk about how to
learn to collaborate
thank you martin so i'm sam devlin a
senior researcher at microsoft and in
this final section i want to talk a
little bit about
what happens uh when we try to apply
single agent reinforcement learning
to multi-agent tasks such as the games
that we've talked about so far today
in this section i want to include some
of our recent research that provides
scalable approaches
to learning coordinated policies in
these complex games
so in all the work that we've seen so
far today
we've seen issues when applying directly
applying
single agent reinforcement learning
algorithms to multiplayer tasks
this is why the agents in martin section
didn't coordinate
in particular the challenge is that if
we just naively place multiple
individual learners into the same
environment
the environment appears non-stationary
to any one of them
that is to say that the same observation
and action
matches the different outcomes as the
other agents are also
updating their policies at the same time
in the environment
this causes issues with breaking
fundamental assumptions
in how single agent reinforcement
learning algorithms are designed
uh and in particular for deep
reinforcement learning where it's common
to use a replay buffer
it can cause issues where these
experiences become stale because they're
dependent on the previous policies
of the other agents in the environment
an alternative approach is to just group
all agents as one so if we're trying to
learn a
a joint policy for a group of agents
that we're controlling
then why not just stick them all into
one big agent that controls all of them
this can be done certain use cases but
it does lead to an exponential increase
in the state action space
which then leads to even more training
time needed
and as deep reinforcement learning
algorithms are typically very sample
intensive
having this exponential increase in the
state action space can be very
problematic making it intractable for
many people to be able to train agents
in this way
from our perspective looking at gaming
applications even worse than this
it can be considered as cheating a lot
of these games
are designed so that you have a partial
observability based on where you
currently are in that space
so if we allow all the agents in the
game to see what everyone else is doing
then that's not how the game is played
one way to work around these two issues
is to use the paradigm of centralized
training for decentralized execution
so in this approach the agents are
considered as one
whilst training so we use all of the
data that can be generated from all
agents
during training and then we learn
policies that can be decoupled at the
time that we deploy them
so this framework is used a lot in many
modern
deep multi-agent reinforcement learning
approaches
it uses the same assumption as many
recent distributed reinforcement
learning algorithms such as
impala and it's the simplest but most
effective way
to to quickly learn a coordinated policy
in particular this gets used to learn
often
to learn a centralized critic and
there's an example implementation in
the rl lib docs for how to do this with
the setup
that we've provided and talked about in
the earlier sections
in any project where i'm trying to learn
coordinated policies for multiple agents
this approach with a centralized critic
would always be my first go-to
as a safe bet for potentially learning a
reasonable enough policy
as we dive deeper into some of the
problems that come up
i want to take a look at this particular
instance of one of the games that we
talked about earlier
in this situation uh one of the agents
has trapped the mob
in the far corner and the other one is
not really doing anything it's just
standing here in the corner looking at
what's going on
in a team game where both agents are
rewarded the same based on
how they're performing as a team both
agents here would receive a positive
reward because one of the agents has
captured the mob
but the other agent who's not really
helping will also get a positive reward
and so may learn that standing in the
corner doing nothing is a useful
behavior
this is known as the multi-agent credit
assignment problem how do we
break down a global reward so that each
agent understands what its contribution
is and learns policies that are actually
useful to contributing towards the team
[Music]
one approach to tackle this is
difference rewards
uh so this was originally proposed by
david walper and khan toomer in a 1999
nasa tech report
under the name the wonderful life
utility
formally this takes the approach where
instead of receiving just the shared
team reward that the game
gives each agent instead receives a
shaped reward
which is the difference between what the
global team reward was
and what it would have been if that
agent didn't exist or had followed some
sort of default policy
by doing so we get to reward the agents
based on their actual contribution
to the game rather than how the team is
doing overall
if each agent tries to maximize its
contribution then typically
the team will perform better this is a
multi-agent specific form of reward
shaping
designed to remove the noise created by
actions of the other agents in the
environment
so each agent gets a clear signal about
what they are actually contributing to
the game
so this approach was proposed originally
in 1999
and there was over a decade of very
successful applications of this to
collaborative games
however it made one fundamental
assumption that you had direct access to
the reward function
so that you could calculate that right
hand far right hand term
[Music]
where what the global reward would have
been if you weren't there or if you'd
taken a default action
this isn't always possible and so in
this 2014 paper uh by mitch colby
khan and colleagues they propose to
instead that
you learn the reward function so that
you can then
query it with this for this second term
to find out what it might have been if
you weren't in the environment
this line of work was then built on
further by jacob forrester and
colleagues
in their triple ai 2018 paper
that extended it into a deep
reinforcement learning approach
where they instead use the value
function of a centralized critic so
again they're using this
uh paradigm of centralized training
decentralized execution
they learn a centralized critic and then
they calculate the difference rewards of
the value function
from the central value function instead
this allowed them to scale up to
some tasks within starcraft
and other complex games using the the
flexible abilities of
deep nets as a value function
approximation
in a more recent upcoming paper that i
was involved in
have proposed doctor reinforce another
deep reinforcement lending approach
that instead returns back to the concept
of learning the reward function
this is because learning a centralized q
function can be prohibitively
challenging
so if we can learn just the reward
function rather than having to learn
the more forward looking q function we
might be able to get
a more efficient way of estimating the
difference rewards
while still gaining the benefits that
coma had by using deep
reinforcement learning to learn our
policy
let's have a look at how this performs
in practice
[Music]
so in this paper we we considered a
smaller version of our mob chase game
where we have three agents trying to
capture a mob or prey
pictured as the red square by
experimenting in this simpler
environment
we were able to compare against earlier
methods that had direct access to the
reward function
so that that past decade of work that i
alluded to earlier
when we have free agents like this we
can see that all methods are performing
relatively well
the the lines in particular to look at
here is the green line
the top left corner as the best
performing agent learns very quickly to
achieve the highest performance
this agent is the one that used the
previous assumption that you had access
to the reward function
so it's it can directly calculate the
difference reward and not approximate it
whereas our agent in the dark blue line
which is having to learn the reward
function online whilst the agents are
acting
is able to recover the same performance
fairly quickly after that agent is but
all agents
uh are acting fairly similar um
we see uh coma is also com competitive
here
uh and the colby agent from the original
2014 paper
one of the big things i would take away
from this is that any time that you're
using difference rewards they are still
outperforming
the naive approach of just placing
multiple individual learners in the
environment
however as we increase the number of
agents in this environment
we see that the effect size becomes
larger and the methods start to separate
and in this case we see that our
approach using
uh doctor reinforce where learning the
reward function and still using a deep
reinforcement learning approach to
learning the policy
is able to handle more agents in the
environment
which we believe is down to this
difficulty in learning
the centralized q function with coma
which is again
evidenced in the final poll on the far
right where coma is now performing worse
than the original porridge by colby
despite having a more powerful function
approximation
for the policy whereas colby has a more
limited version but is again learning
the reward function
and not the joint q value we're still
exploring
the cause of all of these differences
and how this approach scales to more
complex environments
uh but this is one approach that has
been tested in a wide variety of
scenarios
for learning more coordinated policies
and overcoming that challenge of
multi-agent credit assignment
so i want to move on now to a slightly
different problem
and something we saw when we proposed
originally proposed these tasks as a
competition in 2018
in that competition we had a number of
participants submit agents that perform
very well
when playing the games with another
instance of their own agent
right so if we have the the two agents
in the left box they perform
very well with another instance of
itself uh similar with the ones on the
right
however if we took one agent from each
of these
uh these teams so these are two agents
trained by different teams
but both perform well when when in a
team with another one of themselves
they don't necessarily perform well
together there can be miscoordination
due to assumptions that the agent is
making about the other agent
in its environment even more bizarre
we found that if you train two instances
of the same agent using exactly the same
code base
but just a different random seed they
can often be uncoordinated and not play
the game well together
this is known as the ad hoc teamwork
problem what we want
is agents to to be able to play with any
other agent without any prior
coordination
so the agents in this competition so far
have been
have strictly relied on the fact that
they have trained with the other agent
and that they've formed um
concepts on how they should be taking
different roles within that game
but ultimately we want an agent that can
recognize who they're playing with
and adapt to them so they play online
well with them
formally this extends the normal
multi-agent mdp objective which tries to
maximize the accumulated reward
of all agents in the environment to
and the extension just includes an
expectation over the other possible
agents
so we wanted to perform well on average
across all agents that it's going to
play with
in the environment this was
uh particularly well summed up in this
uh challenge paper from
aaai 2010 by peter stone and colleagues
where they talk about human ability of
ad hoc teamwork
to do things like play pickup games at
basketball
right we should as humans be able to
play a game that we're good at
with anybody that that we meet maybe
with a brief period of coordination at
the beginning
but we shouldn't completely fall apart
and not be able to adapt to them
and that's ultimately what we want for
the agents and what we're trying to
challenge
trying to achieve when taking on the ad
hoc teamwork challenge
so to go after this challenge we
proposed this method recently
that's upcoming at the armas conference
this year
so this looks like a a nightmarish bit
of a network
but i can break this down into four
simple stages
where this represents the network that
is our policy for this agent
first we observe the behavior of other
agents in other
in our environment this can be done
online once the agent is learning as in
this paper
or from a power batch of data for
instance replays of human players
playing this game on public servers
our network architecture includes an
information bottleneck for which these
observations must be compressed
from this compressed representation we
then try to predict the future actions
of the other agents
the error in our predictions can be used
to update the parameters in the blue
encoder to maximize the information
retained from the observations
that is needed to predict the future
actions we factor these
per agent which allows us to scale well
in the number of agents
but you could also do a joint prediction
hero for those
actions of the other agents
from that that training of the uh
the top two sections we get this
compressed representation
that is attempting to capture our belief
over the other agents
um we did this in a way so that there
there are two versions separated here
one
that that will stay stable throughout
the entire episode
which is our intention that is trying to
capture the play style of the other
agent
and another that changes per time step
which is hoping to capture the current
mindset
so you might be playing with someone
that plays in a particular style
but recognize that they've maybe gone
into a particular mode within that style
and we do this uh with a variational
auto encoder like structure so we are
both capturing
our our a current mean estimate
but also some variance over this to try
and capture some uncertainty over
our current belief of the other agent's
playstyles and mindsets
in the final stage we can then condition
our policy
on that current belief of the other
agents so instead of just trying to
choose an action based off of the
current state
we choose our action based off of both
the current state and our current belief
of the other agents in our environment
if those beliefs are currently highly
uncertain our agent may learn to perform
information gathering actions to infer
more about the the other agents in the
environment that they're acting with
or if it's in a critical stage of the
game it may choose to act despite this
uncertainty
for instance in the mob chase scenario
if the mob was about to escape
the agent might choose to capture it
even if it doesn't know that
the other agent will be there to support
it either way the agent now adapts to
others in
in in its environment instead of
assuming that they will adapt to
accommodate the agent
finally to demonstrate this approach in
practice i'll show this on
another small game that we used in the
paper
so in this game we have two agents that
are collecting coins
that they want to take to the bank red
coins must be taken to the red bank
blue coins to the blue bank the team is
rewarded
collectively so this is a fully
collaborative game where they both want
to maximize the number of coins they can
take to the bank in a fixed period of
time
we are controlling the agent with the
fort bubble but we have no control over
the agent in the bottom left corner
this agent might have a preference for
particular types of coins
might prefer to take the coin that's
always closest to it it might always try
and take the coin that's furthest away
from it
depending on how that other agent is
acting
our agent needs to recognize it and
adapt and
play the game differently and what we
see
when we apply our method in this this
approach
so our method is here is the bamel
uh we see far higher average return than
some
comparative methods from the literature
so first we have the dashed line
dash gray line which is a typical model
free approach
with a feed forward network for a policy
so this agent takes no consideration of
other agents in the environment
it's just learn on average how to best
respond to
all of the agents it's seen during
training
alternatively our approach can be seen
as a metal learning approach
where it is learnt over a population of
other agents that it's trained with
so we compared to the rl squared
algorithm with the green line
which is a state-of-the-art
meta-learning approach with a recurrent
network
as we can see both of our approaches
significantly outperform
these these two baseline approaches if
we look a little deeper
into this and we can also see a
potential cause for why this is
happening
so in this next plot what we're trying
to do here is predict
what the other agent is in the
environment so this wasn't
a part of the training loop for either
agent but what we do is once the agents
are trained
or at various time steps throughout
training we take the current
intermediate representation
and attempt to predict from that what
the other agent is
so this is a separate supervised
learning problem
uh just to use to probe what is what is
being learned in the intermediate
representations of these agents
and what we see is that from the
intermediate layers of the rl squared
agent
it remains throughout training quite
challenging to predict what the other
agent is doing
so this agent is not retaining
information about what the other agent
in the environment is doing
whereas with our beymol approach that
intermediate representation
can after training be used to
to accurately predict what the other
agent is
showing that it is retained information
critical to understanding who
this agent is playing with so to close
i i just want to summarize some of the
core problems that occur
in multi-agent reinforcement learning
and some of the methods that we've
talked about today to overcome them
first if we just naively place multiple
single agent reinforcement learning
algorithms into the same environment
then we introduced the problem of
non-stationarity which breaks many
standard
assumptions in rl algorithms causing
them not necessarily to
converge towards an optimal policy
secondly we have the curse of
dimensionality where if we put all of
these agents into one monolithic agent
that has to control all of them
then we get an exponential growth in the
state action space
which can be intractable to learn then
we talked about the multi-agent credit
assignment problem
where it's hard for an agent to
understand from a global team reward
what it did to contribute towards that
that team
score and so here we talked about
difference rewards as an approach
to give more informed credit to the
agents that actually contributed to the
success of the team
and finally we talked about ad hoc
teamwork and this is the problem of
an agent that has to generalize to
another agent
which it hasn't previously coordinated
with so how do you learn
an agent's policy that can generalize to
a wide range of other partner agents
that they might play with
we talked a little bit about some
approaches to this but
interested listeners uh i would
recommend these
two surveys too that cover a wide range
of past methods
both uh from the sort of deep pre-deep
reinforcement learning era in the first
survey from
2008 and also a very recent survey that
covers a large portion of
the the approaches that have been
proposed more recently
in the deep reinforcement learning
paradigm
the approaches that i've covered today
have not yet been tested in the
multi-agent minecraft tasks my
collaborators presented earlier
so i invite all those on the call today
to try these approaches out
and would love to hear the learnings of
anybody in the audience that gained
uh insights by applying these approaches
in those multi-agent problems in
minecraft
finally before we start the q a session
i would just like to invite you all to
join us
for our upcoming ai and gaming research
summit which will be taking place on
february 23rd and 24th
2021 there's a link there for
registration and for
any of the resources that we make
available after the event uh this would
be a great opportunity to learn about
far wider range of research in this area
looking both at ai agents in other
settings but also topics such as
responsible gaming computational
creativity and understanding players
thank you
hello everyone many thanks to all of you
for attending the refusal learning in
minecraft
seminar today and also for staying for
this live
q a so i'm diego perez i'm one of the
corporations of the presenters of this
webinar
with me uh roluk again matiba and sam
dublin who will be also answering your
questions
um you have probably seen that we've
answered already some of your questions
in the chat
and now we're going to take some extra
questions
that have been submitted by you uh we've
selected to reply
live now so let's get started with this
um the first one
is uh it's a question submitted by lucas
from university of edinburgh
and i'll answer the question now so did
you observe for the game
ml meta learning work that the variance
and uncertainty
of the v a e was interpretable
could you for example observe that the
variance increase
whenever the other agents executed
behavior rarely or not seen during
training before
and hence including the play styles
could be difficult
um fingers sam is gonna answer this
sure thanks for the question lucas uh
so in in the example that we showed in
the talk
uh it was a little harder for us to
interpret what was
in the later representation learned by
the vae due to the size
that we uh we chose to encode it as
however in the paper that supports this
work we did look at a game with
where we were able to use a far smaller
latent representation and there it was a
very interpretable
representation that was learned so we
see things like that it was counting the
actions that the other agents were
taking
that it was clearly separating the
different types of agents that they
trained against
in all of those cases what we did see
was that the variants would reduce
over time when it was recognizing a
behavior so once it
had seen from the history that it it had
more confidence over which agent it was
playing with
but what we didn't explore was looking
at how do we generalize
beyond agents that are in that that
training set so
i think that's the the really exciting
part in in lucas's question about having
the agent actually recognize uh when
it's playing with someone that it
doesn't recognize
i think that's a really key thing for
future work these agents need to be able
to
learn how to acknowledge that they're in
a position where they don't understand
what's going on
and so take more information gathering
actions uh i know lucas and
the team at edinburgh are also working
on this so really keen to see what they
do in that space maybe has something to
to share with us all soon
all right thank you um this next
question is by the way tongue
from q11 uh there are actually quite a
few questions in one so i'm going to
split this in
in two parts uh so starting with uh with
the first one is the sign of the
structure in
d neural network important in il uh do
you use a general neural network for
different games and
are these hyper parameters of the dnn
tuned for every game
yeah so another good question yeah i can
jump on that
um so another good question uh obviously
ideally we wouldn't want to have to be
tuning these specifically for every
single game
but in practice that's still the way
we're mostly doing things
uh there's a very interesting line of
work on making dparel
more generalizable more robust and this
is something we explored
i posted a paper in the questions to our
europe's 2019 paper on this topic
so we're definitely exploring options
for for network architectures that allow
more generalization
we've particularly found that the uh
variation
null information bottleneck is
beneficial for doing so
but still a wide open question
particularly for looking at that
challenge of generalizing across
different games
uh we're also exploring this from
another perspective of
uh working with colleagues at msr new
york
from a more cognitive neuroscience
background are looking at more sort of
neuro-inspired architectures
that can encode more human-like priors
to get more human-like behavior
out of our agents that we hope would
then be broadly applicable to a whole
range of games
and as a follow-up if the this input
is an image do you need a
state-of-the-art image processing
or a simple model can be used
so so this is somewhere where our team
differs a little bit we we work very
closely with game studios and
with the uh in this instance with the
malmo
uh the way malmo is set up we can get
access to more
low-level game state from the game
itself uh we don't see an advantage
in many of our games for operating at
that sort of per pixel level
so a lot of this work is done off of a
lower level game state
taking access to taking the advantage of
the fact that we have access to the game
so you can learn a lot more sample
efficient than uh
doing things at the the pixel level
okay fantastic um we've got another
question from ashwin
uh with vinay from the university of
buffalo
considering that this is a stochastic
environment uh how do we
how do the agents act based on the
probability and are the choice of states
random or based on
certain transition priority and i think
some can also reply that
sure so um for the majority of the work
that we do we use
a policy gradient or actor credit based
algorithms so that we can learn
stochastic policies
particularly in multi-agent settings
this is very important
i think quite follow the second half of
this so the choice of states
uh will very much be based off of the
transition probability within the
environment
it is probabilistic but these algorithms
are
able to deal with that the part that we
do sometimes randomize though is about
uh generating lots of different
instances so that the agents get trained
in different settings
uh this is both for um
making the agents more robust it's a
method popularly known as domain
randomization
uh but it's also something that we do in
in these uh
these environments when we ran them as
competitions to ensure that we could
provide
test set environments that the
participants had previously trained on
all right i hope that covers it
okay there's another question by hamsa
sorry if i'm pronouncing the
the names incorrectly from ryerson
university
um so i'm a student i don't know too
much about employing reinforcement
learning in games
how would you recommend i get study with
this field
uh and i believe martin bala can answer
this
there you go yeah so this is a good
question
i would recommend starting by learning a
bit about the
theory of reinforcement learning and
there are some good lectures
on youtube that you can follow um
and i recommend you picking up item
programming
if you don't know it already
and then open ai scheme have very good
examples to
get started with it
okay so thank you
let's see other questions
from kimbeau lee
from university of cambridge recent
researching draft new networks
also have been actively investigated to
build up decentralized multi-agent
problems
related wars show that this can be
helpful for generalization performance
that train in 10 agents but tested in a
larger scale
as also addressed in your work have you
considered the applications of gnns
in your team um i know some if you can
answer this in your team sure
um yeah so it's not something we've
experimented with yet
um but it is a very exciting direction
uh i
again i know that uh jing bao and the
the group at cambridge are doing some
really exciting work in this space so
uh we'd love to see uh if that can scale
to
to these tasks in malo like this this is
why we put these environments out there
really is
to see uh see how the
uh community can sort of engage with
these problems and try out these
different approaches
uh there's only so much bandwidth within
one team to try out new ideas but
graph neural networks are definitely a
very powerful tool for approaching these
okay thank you we're gonna
leave a couple of minutes in case
somebody else has another question
so i did i did have one uh that that i
didn't get quite around to
responding to in my in my badge uh so
from
sagar ubretti at the university of
warwick
asked how we define mindset in the uh
the paper on ad-hoc teamwork
um and so here we we we weren't
explicitly defining them essentially we
have
two variables in late and representation
one that's only sampled once
per game and one that's being sampled
per time
step and so really the the labeling of
it as a mindset
is more just a way for us to uh
interpret and communicate our intention
with those two different components
it's actually something that was
originally defined in the machine theory
of mind paper
a few years back um i can't remember the
reference directly from my head but it's
it decided in the paper for where that
one came from
but yeah so the mindset i believe was
the per time step one
so we capture the the overall play style
with the
per episode so you have a particular
play style
that you're dear to throughout uh when
you play whereas the mindset is more
that sort of
moment-to-moment reaction and how these
might change based on what's currently
going on
that's great thank you
uh this is another question uh by
uc liu from qmul uh he says hello in
terms of learning all agency monkeys and
platform
uh how to learn the other agent
efficiently uh given the data for the
region is
is too limited in addition come the
method of learning
other agents being implemented into the
national game
to learn about the point again um
well actually multi-agent learning is
something that has been
has been researched for for many many
years that is one of the main
research questions that is at the moment
and normally what the people
try to do uh the most said to to
implement or create
a model of the of the opponent by
basically
trying to analyze uh the title and the
policy that this opponent is going to be
executing uh
by basically starting data for playing
uh often i guess i guess with these
games versus this uh this
agents and trying to build this
this model uh in a in a more or less
dynamic manner um
i i don't know if if anyone else wants
to add something else
to this or any particular ways in which
maybe microsoft
is doing this
your research yeah so so i think um
the the example i presented at the end
was probably the the best one i
i have to mind was learning that model
uh in a competitive game it's absolutely
the case that if
if you learn the model then that that's
a way to exploit
a particular opponent um beyond playing
just a nash equilibria that's safe
against
and robust to a whole range of opponents
um in the in the paper that's linked for
the ad hoc teamwork
setting we do have a game that is uh
more competitive than
than the example that i showed so
it is equally applicable in that setting
but i'm really motivated by that
application of using it for fully
collaborative games
i mean ideally what we want is for these
agents to empower the player
and enable the player to do more rather
than exploit them or try to beat them
it's quite easy to make agents that are
very good at games and be
people it's much more fun to create
agents that
can allow more people to enjoy games
okay there are no more questions coming
up we can
wait a minute just in case somebody's
typing
probably a good chance just to make sure
everybody's seen the
the invite in the resource list to our
ai and gaming summit next week
uh so the registration is open until
tomorrow so please do sign up today if
you're interested
there's a there's going to be a lot of
work there that's going to span
a range of different topics in game ai
uh
including lots of stuff on uh
collaborative agents collaborating with
humans
uh but also going into things such as
computational creativity
responsible gaming and understanding
players so hopefully of wide interest to
people on
this call today
[Music]
okay so i think we we might be ready to
start wrapping up um so thank you thank
you for attending today
we appreciate your participation your
questions your interest in the subject
this tutorial is going to be available
on demand very very shortly as
after these q a finishes
and if you are interested to learn more
as some just said
we have a list of great resources in the
resource list
to the right of your screen uh so as you
can see it was there
we do have the presentation slides that
that this
webinar we've been using the webinar we
have a couple of links to the project
malmo
the actual research project in microsoft
research
and also the uh the link to the latest
repository
in github so you can you can find the
the final examples on the final code
that has been implemented
there are also a couple of reference to
revlon papers that we have been
mentioning today during the
during the webinar so there are there
two
to reference to archive papers and as
also some just mentioned uh the latest
one is
is a link to the ai and gaming recent
summit who's happening
uh next week 23rd to the 4th of february
uh the recession is free uh but it's
gonna be
closing tomorrow so basically try to
reduce the bike tomorrow the latest
um is it's gonna be a very very
interesting event there's lots lots of
different
topics being converted in the event uh
to two full days of work
and talk on rl and gamingi and so on
yeah so let's check that out and and we
will we look forward to seeing you
uh see how you build all of these
research and how you prosper there
uh the boundaries of rl and game ai
and we're looking forward to seeing your
your work so thank you
again for tuning in and have a great day